بوادر الحوار والمصالحه ترتسم معالمها في
اثيوبيا تزامنا مع رفع جبهه تحرير من
قائمه الجماعات المصنفه ارهابيا وانشاء
اداره مؤقته للمنطقه بعد قرابه سنتين من
الحرب التي استنزفت الطرفين خطوه من شانها
تعزيز السلام والاستقرار في البلاد اذا
تمكنت الاطراف من تعميم لغه الحوار مع
كافه الجماعات المسلحه تمشيا مع بنود
الاتفاق المبرم في نوفمبر الماضي مكتب
رئيس الوزراء اليثيوبي عينه
البارزه في جبهه التحرير تيجري رئيسا
للحكومه المؤقته وهي خطوه رئيسيه ستسمح
للجبهه بالعوده للساحه السياسيه وخلق ثقه
متبادله بين الاطراف
الاجراء وفق مراقبين للتطورات الحاصله
سيشجع اطرافا اخرى معارضه للمطالبه بازاله
اسمها عن لوائح الارهاب المحليه في
المرحله المقبله فالكثير من الاثيوبيين
يعملون في ان تدفع هذه الخطوه الى تسريع
تطبيق كافه مخرجات اتفاق السلام المبرم في
نوفمبر الماضي ووضع الاساس الصحيح الذي
يضمن العوده الى دوله مستقره وامنه بعد ان
شغل النزاع في تيجري طيله الفتره الماضيه
المجتمع الدوليه والمحلي